[Música]
o assunto pessoal de quem falar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo o
enchimento 100 vídeo com messi e mérito
em primeiro lugar só quero pedir
desculpa por ficar de dois meses quase
dois meses sem fazer vídeos mas eu
preciso mesmo de parar só porque o réu
[Música]
aquela casa que vocês viram
anteriormente era uma casa temporária eu
não podia fazer muito feliz lá por
questões de contrato do popular mil
muita burocracia muita coisa chata que
eu não posso falar aqui inclusive 2008
foi um ano bem complicado porque como
vocês viram não gostei sim tantos vídeos
aqui no canal mas vai tudo voltar ao
normal agora em 2019 sol sério vai mesmo
mentira e sim este é o quarto novo sim
uma casa nova sim estou a viver com um
pico dentro e na ces reuters você entrar
no cnis filho pensa que o irã aumenta
com a marca não vocês estão enganados e
e e vocês fãs que estão aqui ainda
espera construir uma conteúdo só se
centrarão que ficaram tristes a pensar
como é que vai o canal que irá ser muito
muito motivado e muito feliz agora com
esta casa nova e vamos mostrar tudo aqui
neste vídeo portanto 2019 vai ser o
nosso enoque escrevo isso na pedra deixe
um sol porque ela vai que os dias em que
as pedras não crescer não sou um
analfabeto já partilham este vídeo com
os nossos amigos mandou a tap mantém
própria turma nem pro twitter de comprar
frango motoristas e viris de cuidar pra
tentar voltar o canal e vocês foram
couros preciso muito a nossa ajuda para
ninguém mesmo muito muito inclusive
temos um novo animal de estimação não
vai andar frei na casa portanto se
apanhar em alguns pólos
eu vou estar aqui tanto fiquem bem
atentos e assim os cantinhos e tal
porque o poder aqui passear e este é o
quarto novo olha isso é bem grande é bem
espaçoso estaria que a minha direita
barcelona eu vou passar mais tempo
editar os vídeos e gravar os
investimentos mas não vou fazer todos os
temporais e investimento vai ser um jogo
e ditar tudo nos vídeos fazem mt que o
gráfico e equi eo direito eu pelo menos
acho que assim vai ficar bem mais
prática e portanto vamos ver se resulta
e aqui neste espaço pessoal vai ser um
governo é flexível os gato lei 4 onde
possa eventualmente fazer um vídeo assim
vai ser aqui nesta zona e é que ela está
destinada a instalar janela eu vou botar
os games mais pessoal portanto se
quiserem jogar alguma coisa comenta e eu
tô muito viciada em pedir o mobile então
eu não sei se vocês estão muito
interessados em ver esse tipo de
conteúdo aqui mas de qualquer forma vou
fazer porque eu adoro jogo então eu vou
fazer depois de pedir mobile caiu se
dispor a zona de tv da cama porque
quando ia para a cama eu ficava muito
tempo a ver séries e ficava
tempos jogar basicamente o que esperar
um sono do brasileiro então sim eu tenho
certeza que sempre que for pra cama eu
vou ficar ali ia dormir e descansar bem
e não vou sair e beber outras coisas
então acho que isso vai ajudar muito o
meu sono eu preciso muito cansado o
primeiro e agora vai passar aqui
profundo quarta é que nessa zona pessoa
vai ficar o merchandising que vai ser
muito em breve portanto espera em
primeiro e nem o imposto de renda
enquanto china que tem algumas séries
antigas digimon adoro é que tem um rumo
que em alguns personagens páginas é
fredes e tv
aqui tenho posso imaginar sem fred
seque-os coelho vai ser o meu gosto da
minha roupa e e masculino base que vai
dividir um quarto por zonas e tesoura do
trabalho zona de lazer da zona do
descanso ea zona do tentar ficar bonito
eu tenho uma coisa que o pessoal está no
chiquérrimo está quieto grávidas ea
formação portanto consumar aqui tudo
pode esconder aqui coisas que eu não
quero que vocês vejam fica um monte de
tralha cabos fios muita coisa aqui pode
esconder aqui tudo tem que as colunas um
dever nem por ele tem uma lei outra aqui
todos os lugares aqui da casa tem som
inclusive as casas de banho então
imaginem só eu vou à sala coloca música
e toda a casa uma música que eu estou
ouvindo isso é bom para fazer algumas
franquias tanto comenta e já de idéia
imaginem só um sons texturas imposto da
casa do pessoal vai ficar louco pio não
fica muito assustados vamos saber então
casa vai entrar muito arrumada mas para
eu sair eu saí windows organizar o
estoque a nós já fizemos temos aqui há
apenas três dias 34 dias no máximo então
tá sendo a procura para arrumar o estudo
e deixar em condições pouco mais forte
demanda nenhum problema é tão gostoso
que falamos
funciona pode estar em breve méxico é
muito novo e jacuzzi e teve um goleiro
muito bom quinhão solo tem muito
mistério sempre quis ter um quarto assim
tem tudo aqui do que eu preciso
trabalhar à vontade para descansar à
vontade e dá pra mim ter a vontade e
agora pessoal nós vamos ver o quarto do
pib durante e depois vamos passar a sala
à piscina e não sei se vocês já deram
conta do animal de estimação que eu
tenho aqui a nar
eu não saí fiquei sem saber embora pois
não falo do meu time e grupal e michael
jackson em campo muito bom
o uso e ii e aí opinó está em casa mas
eu aproveitei mas já o quartel este é o
quarto deu também é bem grande também
tem uma casa de banho dentro esta queima
de westerns onde vai trabalhar aqui é um
deus pai filho e vamos pra casa dormir
por causa do vento uma coisa muito
interessante muito louca
assim em rio branco mt o quarto pior
vamos ver o quarto dante eu acho que tá
a gravar porque eu havia alguns barulhos
concentrar na sobrancelha que eu vou
fazer eu acho que eu preciso de ajuda
eu não vou fazer nada sobre os olhos
para não acontecer nada você precisa
ajudar a cair sim é sim
[Música]
o mundo foi o danton foi fui aí de tanto
dançar fui um preço ocorrendo no futuro
levar tudo o que se diga consigo horário
em que aconteceu a gente fizesse isso
mas como estava sua pior que está não
fica é o tamanho ea irmã sua base que
vem em terceiro quarto dando também é
bem grande é quase igual ao do píer casa
rendeu também uma hidromassagem falei
[Música]
meu deus você quer mais acaba eu vou
continuar aqui fazer o meu
até já o que acabou de acontecer eu só
estava a filmar o quarto dela e ela quer
modificar sem sombra célia ela ia mandar
baixo
o que é isto que é isso e colocou o
nosso animal de estimação carga muito
carga muito ééé cargo ou não sei se
vocês já ouviram aqui neste frio mas
fiquem atentos com destaque para um
canto qualquer um só que vamos buscar a
nossa salvei jansle gol
ang o melhor da nossa sala só estes o
falso faz gigante absurdamente grandes
fala 30 pessoas em sua lista não se
salva nós temos aqui também a tv já tá
ali playstation 4 instalada nós temos
jogado aqui um pouco que tem um tapete
leandro tem que surfar em que este lobby
também para as visitas ficar aqui ou ali
tão fato é que essa aula e não aprende é
logo aqui só adiantar aqui é cozinhada
nenhuma ação social muito boa
outra coisa que eu tenho muito tempo
para aprender foi a usar um microondas
uma coisa tão simples mas repete e nunca
vi um microondas tanques pessoal digamos
vocês têm micro instante stop e ainda
abre a porta com o técnico
não digo que isso não é incrível eu vou
exagerar eu não eu tenho de jogar não
não é isso é muito incrível eu não
preciso disso a gente tem muito isso é
muita futura pra mim e não tenho planos
assim pelo menos um animal daqui da casa
já destruiu duas pantufas olha aí está o
algodão de uma pantufa neste caso aquela
queda decorre num balão turista e okaka
no tapetão roy as pantufas e também
comida deu inclusive terá que fazer já
acham que só acham com ela o que é um
rato é um rato quando e como md ficam e
andré e vamos ao demonstrar que o resto
da casa
aí é que as limpezas das tribunas as
pessoas acham que não interessa muito é
e tudo na rua casa a casa mãe tem que os
quatro
[Música]
gostava dessa casa olha só a casa toda
aberta
eu gostava do meu deus pois é isso então
contem pessoal com algum tipo de
brincadeira aqui na sala com uma guerra
não foi qualquer coisa sem torcida
contente com isso e janelas elétricas
meus amigos janelas elétricas
aqui está nossa piscina pessoal no verão
vai ser muito bom vai ser aqui e aqui
tem uma churrascaria também dá pra fazer
muita carne aqui mais uns poemas do novo
animal de estimação e poderá ser campeão
e moça interpretem como quiserem porque
isso não vai dar a vocês a garagem e
temos aqui muitos passes por entre
carros e esta pessoal é a nossa casa
digam lá se esta casa não é muito
parecida casa 12 de outubro é meu é
muito parecida à fachada dela é mesmo
muito por cima e quando vi esta casa eu
pensei que estava lá mas não esta casa e
outra como vocês podem ver o interior é
completamente diferente mas a casa porém
muito parecido eu adoro este tipo de
construção portanto fiquei logo com ela
ok só mas vamos lá vamos aprendendo a
exportar fazer mau tempo vai começar a
chover agora mas o verão tá mesmo sair
arrebentado vai ser muito louco aqui
fora e outra coisa é ficar aqui no
corredor que vocês se vocês repararam a
pouco e me tranquilo eu trouxe a também
pra que claro não poderia ficar sem ela
eu acho que não está a dormir
está muito saudável pessoal determinada
turma muito em conta dela não está aqui
ô ô ô ô
eu tenho conhecimento pra ela
também teve envolvimento pessoal e aí
pessoal vai colocar o brigadeiro
recolocar a minha taranco é que no meio
da sala para toda a gente ver é porque
ela é do clima tropical levar mais um
ano e portanto ela tem que ter tanto
calor como o sol então acho que ficarei
bem quem chegou ninguém chegou muito
xixi por um tempo só nós temos aqui
pequeno escritório que eu ainda não sei
qual é um dos que eu vou dar mas que
eventualmente vamos fazer que vídeos
também
basicamente isto é um escritório em
frente à piscina
basicamente ele só vocês já viram casa
tudo vamos voltar aqui pro quarto deste
play box nanómetros óxi no estado mas só
os pratos que não está aqui nesta casa
nova eu estou muito contente tubo e
motivado quer muito fazer vídeo eu quero
2019 seja o nosso ano portanto quanto
com vocês pessoal já sabe porque com os
nossos amigos comentem bigham que eu
votei o canal não é para toda a gente e
espero que tenham gostado da chela e
comenta e partilhem ativa e sininho
fiquem vai até a próxima
[Música]